uh see the problem i have right now is
uh
having moved to the bay area from new
york i used to go to esther place
boom quick i got my person get my hair
cut
the problem is i moved to san francisco
history astro place
barbershop right what's that dude did
you know do you know like kind of the
story
about ass astral placing like who owns
it and the only thing i knew about
esther place was when i was a kid
in the 80s we would go to the city and
it was 12 bucks
and we'd give the you know the lady who
did it for us you know like
a 20 and we were all stars we got to the
front of the list and we would just all
go get our hair cut
you know like every two months or
whatever the r train there but i don't
know the backstory on astrophysics
it's a famous barbershop from new york
anybody you know in downtown area has
has heard of it
uh great shop old school in and out um
you know no no no no no fuss
but uh just put it this way it's not the
kind of shop where you'd ever want to
think about you know not paying or
walking out or doing anything like that
the guys who ran that shop
oh it was legit some italian guys maybe
yeah yeah yeah yeah
i have a feeling i know what you're
talking about
you probably do want to pay what was
great about astra place i have to say
back in the day was it was such a mecca
of many different cultures because they
cut
white guys hair they got black guy's
hair it was like a it was a bit of a
crossover right
so there were in the 90s when i would go
when i was in school at fordham we go
down there you know you would have
working-class people you'd have hip-hop
people you'd have nyu students you have
gay people straight people
it was really like a cross section of
new york you'd have bankers going
you know all the way down to students to
to grandpa's everybody would just go in
there and get a quick cut
boom you're done right for 12 bucks 15
bucks but the average cut now is 30.
what's the average cut down the united
states for men's
haircut buzz cut yeah on our system this
is about 40
but average across the us probably about
30 24 30 including tip it's getting
crazy uh expensive and then the problem
i have with
everything is it's the hipsters took
over
and they're making barber shops
uh hipster barber shops like public
works and all these
you know places it it's they're kind of
making them cookie cutter
hipster i don't like this hipster trend
yeah i mean nobody likes me nobody likes
nobody self self-identifies or
or likes hipsters for some reason it's
like a term they're like
we already hate sisters are annoying but
nobody claims to be one
um but i know the type of shops you're
talking about you know i personally
those shops are great for our business
you know they charge high price points
that's the problem they want to charge
60 for a quick buzz cut and i'm like
but they you know why because they're
focused on providing an experience
you know that's not the experience i'm
looking for they're they're awesome
experience in and out i love asset place
too you know and
we try to work with all types of shops
but i think there is room i think
there's room in the market for what
they're offering which is clear because
there's been so many of them
that you know there's not a lot of
places guys can go to kind of be
pampered in a masculine way and still
feel you know i'm asking about it and
that that's what they're providing you
know when they're
whispering because they give you the
neck massage and everything yeah yeah
yeah yeah so you get to like still be
like a tough guy but you got your neck
massaged
exactly i gotcha i got you